much of the british press hailed it as a
brexmas
the deal itself more important than the
details
after months of missed deadlines and
tense talks the prime minister
tried to reset the eu-uk relationship
i think this deal means a new stability
and a new uh certainty in what has
sometimes been a fractious
and difficult relationship we will be
your friend your ally
your supporter and indeed never let it
be
forgotten your number one market
reactions to the new deal have varied
from relief
to despair it feels really good to live
in an independent country again i didn't
vote for brexit i
am really gutted to not be part of
europe anymore well i'm delighted we've
got a deal
i mean it's certainly going to i don't
know what the deals obviously haven't
had a chance to read the 2000 pages but
a deal is obviously better no deal
fishing rights had been one of the
slipperiest subjects
the final deal left the uk fishing
industry disappointed
european boats will still drop nets in
british waters
giving up only 25 percent of their catch
quotas
british exporters face new bureaucratic
burdens
with business groups saying they have
little time to prepare
travelers will no longer roam freely
facing the hassle of applying
for visas and residency rights after 90
days across the channel
and uk students will be cut off from the
eu's university exchange program
erasmus the european commission
president turned to shakespeare to
express
her mixed emotions i only feel
quite satisfaction and frankly speaking
relief i know
this is a difficult day for some
and to our friends in the united kingdom
i want to say
parting is such sweet sorrow
the 27 eu governments and the uk
parliament must now sign off on the deal
by december 31st
the deal is done four years after the
people of britain voted by a narrow
margin to leave the european union the
two sides have reached an agreement
that outlines the terms of their future
relationship
the resolution comes just days before a
transition period was due to end
major sticking points in recent months
have included securing a level playing
field on trade
dispute resolution and fishing rights
it's four and a half years
let's take a listen to what eu
commission president ursula fondelein
had to say about this historic moment
the united kingdom is a third country
but it remains a trusted partner
we are long-standing allies
we share the same value and interests
whether it be the cop 26 summit in
glasgow
or the upcoming uk g7
and italian g20 presidencies
the european union and the united
kingdom will stand
shoulder to shoulder to deliver on our
common global goals and british prime
minister boris johnson
has also been addressing the press let's
take a listen to what he's been saying
i think this deal means a new stability
and a new certainty in what has
sometimes been a fractious
and difficult relationship we will be
your friend your ally
your supporter and indeed never let it
be forgotten
your number one market because although
we have left the eu
this country will remain culturally
emotionally historically
strategically geologically
attached to europe
and of course this deal was of a long
time in the making and in many ways it
represents the beginning of what could
be a
long post-brexit journey for the united
kingdom my colleague daniel winter
on the road ahead the deal is done
a crisis averted it's a relief for both
sides
after all half of the uk's trade is with
its european neighbors
and the uk is the eu's third largest
trading partner
the talks were painful but the
alternative was worse pushing the
begrudging neighbors closer together
never has the european union offered so
much to a so-called
third country the uk has enhanced its
decision-making at home
but still has access to the eu market
whereas the eu
has kept a key customer for billions of
euros of goods
a lot will change come the first of
january the biggest the uk will be out
of the eu single market but both sides
will continue to have tariff-free access
to each other's economies
citizens from either side will no longer
have the automatic right to live and
work in each other's territories
there's likely to be delays at borders
as everyone gets used to complicated new
customs systems
and the uk will stop most of its
payments into the eu's budget
selling british wares freely in the eu's
marketplace is the first big step
but britain still has a monumental task
ahead of it
before brexit britain had access to
scores of deals
now it's on a shopping spree bartering
with partners to snap up trade pacts
worldwide
the uk has already signed up 59
countries to continue trading under the
same conditions as with the eu
plus a fresh deal with japan that's 220
billion euros worth of trade
still there are noticeable absences
the u.s would be the big prize but
president-elect biden has voiced
concerns over brexit
which could signal tough negotiations
ahead
canada has agreed a temporary deal while
talks on a permanent trade pact continue
negotiations with australia started in
the summer and are still ongoing
whether the uk will do a trade deal with
the world's second biggest economy china
is an open question
the uk isn't part of the heavyweight eu
economy anymore which could weaken the
uk's hand in these trade talks
the new deal will be a relief on both
sides of the channel
but for britain the toughest times may
lie ahead
experts predict economic growth to slow
living standards
to drop after all brexiteers dreamed of
gaining sovereignty but to buy that
they've given away
their country's international influence
right now the uk needs good news for its
economy
as with everywhere the pandemic has
eaten away at growth
hastening the decline of thousands of
small towns
and cities getting trade humming through
britain's ports will help mitigate those
effects but will the opportunity cost of
brexit
leave the uk far weaker in the world
than it could have been
or will britain confound critics and
build itself into a singapore on the
english channel
the odds are stacked against them but by
getting a deal with the eu
done britons have looked beyond their
island and taken the first important
step
and speaking of looking beyond their own
island let's get the transatlantic view
on this deal from dw business
correspondent jens cuarta in new york
jens this is of course huge news here in
europe how important is this deal for us
investors in particular
yeah well i mean more clarity and less
uncertainty is always good for markets
and actually we do
see a wall street gaining a bit in a
shortened
trading session here on thursday global
trade disputes um also are usually not
necessarily helpful and if we look back
four and a half years ago when we did
have
this surprise brexit vote we also saw
some pressure
on wall street but having that said it's
not necessarily a game changer for
wall street this is mostly between the
uk and
the european um union and investors on
wall street they have so many
um things to deal with um i mean there
is the pandemic we're doing
we do see some slowing growth so we have
all this fight about a new um eight
package so there are really a lot of
things um on the plate but
it is welcome news also on wall street
as i've said
we do see u.s markets slightly to the
upside
okay so us investors have a lot of
things on their mind right now but
of course one of the biggest issues
around brexit was britain wanting to
make
new trading relations in particular with
the rest of the world world where do you
see the relationship between the us and
the uk in the future
yeah i mean we have heard from boris
johnson and there are some indications
that the uk might push forward
a bilateral trade agreement with the
united states the big question is
if it's really in washington's high
priority list
to get those uh this new deal done
anytime soon there is no pressure for
the upcoming president
joe biden um first of all the us
actually has a trade surplus
with the uk so why make big changes at
this
point and then um also boris johnson was
considered to be
rather close with u.s president donald
trump and i'm not so sure
if we have the same feelings between the
upcoming president
joe biden and boris johnson so um
i would be cautious uh to really believe
that we get a new trade deal anytime
soon um do you it might be in the
interest of washington to
really clear things first with the
european union and with china before
they
uh take care of the uk yeah yes caught
in new york thank you very much